[Música]
hola que tal bienvenidos a 5 minutos con
hoy tenemos como invitada a dalila
hipólito un futbolista argentina la
primera futbolista que llegó al fútbol
de italia ya nos acompaña desde la
ciudad de turín hola dalila cómo estás
hola cómo están buenas tardes muchas
gracias por acompañarnos
dalila llegaste a la juventus desde el
fútbol de argentina como ha sido esta
adaptación al fútbol italiano desde esa
llamada su representante que te digo oye
te quiere la juventus bueno la verdad
que mágico no estoy viendo un sueño un
sueño que lo sonido mucho que que soy
chica soñé con convivir del fútbol no
que eso es lo que estoy haciendo hoy en
día y obviamente en un club tan grande
como lo es la juventus no es es un lugar
mágico que estoy disfrutando el día a
día ya tuviste tus primeros minutos en
herencia de partido contra san martín en
la liga italiana qué diferencias hay
respecto al fútbol argentino como ha
sido la recepción con tus compañeras la
relación con las campeonas de italia
sí sí fuerte fuerte no de las campeonas
italianas pero bien bien tuve la suerte
toda la fortuna y obviamente el equipo
es es un gran equipo grandes jugadoras
las cuales me integraron rápidamente no
tuve problema en cuanto a la integración
en cuanto a él a adaptarme al día a día
a ellas
que soy una afortunada no me puedo
quejar obviamente por eso porque porque
es realmente un gran de un grupo que
trabaja con mucha profesionalidad y creo
que eso después lo hacen ver en la
cancha dentro del campo de juego a
diferencia de argentina el fútbol de
alta es muy dinámico mucho más rápido en
la que hiciste pensar por tres por
tercera vez sacaron la pelota y fuiste
pero pero eso es un poco la diferencia
quizás no no se ve mucha gambeta como
como en argentina no en argentina estoy
acostumbrada
a tener un poco más la pelota un poco
más en los pies pero pero acá me exigen
a hacer dos toques a cambiar el ritmo
estar constantemente en movimiento así
que eso dice es un poco del sudor que me
gusta el ambiente
dalila tú tienes 18 años y ya ha jugado
en la liga argentina
he jugado la copa libertadores ha tocado
mundial de fútbol femenino estás en la
liga italiana vas a jugar champions
seguramente y tienes 18 años como ha
sido todo esto en tan poco tiempo en tu
carrera y qué objetivos tiene después de
haber hecho tanto
bueno es fuerte no cuando me lo pongo a
pensar no estoy acostada y
y que la cabeza empieza a caminar y
empiezan a recordar momentos cosas que
te pasaron en la vida en el camino en
este recorrido de que es una carrera
futbolística
y sé que recién comienza pero sí es
verdad que que pasé por muchos momentos
momentos muy importante en cuanto a lo
futbolístico no y qué significa mucho es
de no creer yo miro para atrás y yo en
qué momento pasó todo esto que no me di
cuenta pero pero si podés de que lo
disfruté al máximo y obviamente di todo
para para poder estar en cada
competición que me tocó estar presente
dalila cuál es la situación del fútbol
argentino a nivel femenino de esa liga
femenina es una liga profesional no
estamos hablando de una liga
semiprofesional
sí sí no no en argentina estamos
empezando si bien es una
profesionalización para muchos y para mí
para nosotras las jugadoras es una semi
profesionalización ya creo que no
podemos decir yo vivo del fútbol en
argentina
y cobras un sueldo un sueldo con el que
podés hacer algo pero no no vivido no
digamos pero pero si puedo destacar que
argentina está haciendo muy bien en el
proceso estamos empezando que empezaron
ya dos después del mundial creo que se
dieron cuenta que tienen que aportar un
poco más por todo el femenino y era hora
que abran los ojos y empiecen a darnos
la importancia que que verdaderamente
nos merecemos no y no te digo que
estamos igual que el masculino pero
estamos avanzando a grandes pasos y creo
que eso es lo importante hoy en día
grandes puestos como por ejemplo el que
conseguiste tú que eres la primera
futbolista que tiene un estadio con su
nombre en argentina lo que hizo el club
de jóvenes deportistas de lugano
daniela muchísimas gracias por este
breve espacio aquí en france 24 te
deseamos lo mejor con la juventus con tu
nuevo equipo ya ustedes muchas gracias
por estar con nosotros quédense porque
hay más mucho más en 324 y 324 puntocom
[Música]